where would you like to live in africa
for all that that that that hoopla about
they took us from africa find me a a
black american that will tell you they
want to move back to africa i will
listen right now or europe
i'll book the fights for them right for
any person that says we were stolen from
our ancestors i can of course and
pledging that i will book the flights if
you renounce your u.s citizenship for
you to go live back in africa you want
you want to cap this at maybe 10 people
just in case people are punking
there's none we did this we did the same
craziness with the trump i hate america
everyone offered their money in flights
i think you might have died
nobody took nobody took the bait right
because they know america is the
greatest place they could possibly live
you know so blackout for me it was i
really wanted to first and foremost lay
out my personal story there's been a lot
of conjecture about where i came from
how i became conservative is she a
fraudulent conservative and
all that craziness because people don't
realize that i just was a political if
anything else like to be clear you're
not some sort of secret agent no
remember you really have been there
through all of this i've been there
since the beginning i mean the youtubers
like digesting my entire life saying
like she must be a plant like i mean a
sorrow's plan i'm like i've never even
voted like i literally prior to getting
getting into things i had i genuinely
just was not politically inclined um and
i just thought i had to be a democrat
and thought i had to be a liberal and
you know looking in the retrospect i
realized how foolish that is um you know
that i didn't realize that everything
was really that everything that bad
happened in my life was really routed to
bad policies and bad politicians um but
i wanted to first lay out just my
personal story um you know the subtitle
of the book is how black america can
make its second escape from the democrat
plantations um and i do believe um i say
this all the time people get upset um
that black americans are still enslaved
today um that the left just got smarter
and they realize that you you can
enslave people um their bodies you can't
have black black americans on the
plantation anymore but you can still
have black americans doing all the work
for you and reaping no benefit and that
is a structure that we see today between
black america and the democratic party
we are doing all the work we get we
carry over the finish line and we
benefit not in one single way um and so
i really kind of lay out that argument
um and then talk about what slave life
was really like the breakdown of family
why it was necessary for families to be
broken down
to trade constantly be trading
slaves from one plantation to the nut to
the next they could they could have no
feelings for one another um at frederick
douglass in his autobiography the first
couple of pages he starts talking about
his life as a slave uh he talks about
the fact that when his mother died he
felt nothing when his sisters were
treated he felt nothing he had no sense
of kinship no no familial love for his
own blood that was necessary to the
institution of slavery we still have
that kinship and that relationship and
that community still broken down all of
these years later later despite the
reconstruction era post slavery uh which
we saw black american families getting
back together we were we were doing
something um it's all been wiped out at
a higher rate by the way until about 72
or so yeah in the 1950s uh black
americans were outpacing whites in terms
of economic growth um and then
immediately following you know the night
the 1960s and the great society act um
and the systemic oppression which
started via the welfare system
everything started falling apart um and
reading another another topic talking
going back to slavery uh black americans
it was illegal for black americans to
learn how to read in fact it was so
illegal that if you were a white person
you were taught and you were and you
were caught teaching you're slave to
read
you would be found guilty too it was a
serious sin the reason for that is uh
because they didn't want black people
being educated because an educated mind
can't be enslaved well what's changed
look at the illiteracy rates in black
america today look at baltimore look at
the inner cities look at where in
california california 70 of black boys
could not pass a basic literacy exam
nobody is talking about that you have
politicians that are standing on stage
saying that all they care about is black
americans they're not talking about
everything that is harming black
americans today everything that is
recreating the very same plantations
that we came from did you catch that
brilliant line that bernie had in one of
the debates which is he wants he's not
only so pro-marijuana that he wants it
to be legal but he also wants to have uh
black community blacks black business
owners owning black marijuana shops
right in black community i did not catch
that and again i say this i say this as
someone that's pro legalizing but like
we're going to incentivize black people
to own black marijuana right shops in
black communities that that right and
and that's and that's why i don't
celebrate by the way why i am
conservative on the marijuana front is
because when you talk about where this
is happening chicago i think just passed
you know marijuana laws it is to me i i
i know it's it's going to lead to more
dysfunction um you know amongst black
america first and foremost because
that's how it always is you know it's
it's what is it about progressive
policies that always leads to
progressive results for the black
community first and foremost and um so i
i i am loathe uh to to be smart enough
to see the debate between uh alcohol and
marijuana so that i can't
firmly but i have a thinking brain and i
just don't see how conservatives can
make a sound argument against it at the
moment
what else has to happen for the black
community to break i'm gonna guess
although i don't have the book yet that
at the end you're gonna you either make
some predictions or you
tell people what tools they need to
really break out of this yeah you know
it's it's not even about making
predictions and i have my own personal
predictions but i definitely am not
doing that in the book i'm giving black
americans a guide i'm giving giving
black americans an option uh the same
option that i saw before me when i
started waking up and i'm having this
conversation with you um you can you can
have the option to accept this victim
narrative right you can have the option
to say i accept this diagnosis of cancer
even though i feel fine walk fine and
have been living fine my entire life i
accept that it's terminal illness and
i'm gonna live like i'm gonna die any
moment
um or or you can you can develop a
different perspective and you can
develop a victor mentality as i say
forget the victim mentality develop a
victor mentality um look back at your
ancestors look back at your your
grandparents look back at what they did
what they lived through the seas that
they planted that you can afford to be
in the circumstance that you are in
today if you are a black american and
you are breathing in the united states
today you are the luckiest among the
luckiest of black people that have ever
lived anywhere on the face of the planet
that is an incredible statement all of
human history the luckiest black people
that have ever lived on the face of the
human planet are the ones that are
living and breathing in america today
okay if you understand that and you
should understand it by simply saying
where would you like to live in africa
for all that that that that hoopla about
they took us from africa find me a a
black american that will tell you they
want to move back to africa i will
listen right now or europe
i'll book the flights for them right for
any person that says we were stolen from
our ancestors i can of course and
pledging that i will book the flights if
you renounce your u.s citizenship for
you to go live back in africa you want
you want to cap this at maybe 10 people
just in case people are punking
there's none we did this we did the same
craziness with the trump i hate america
everyone offered their money in flights
i think you might have died
nobody took nobody took the bait right
because they know america is the
greatest place they could possibly live
um and you know what if someone takes
you up on this i'll guarantee one one
first class upgrade that's amazing i
will do that there we go right here
first class upgrades go to america but
you have to renounce your citizenship to
america and move to africa that's really
what you want to do
as a friend i know that the stuff that
you talk about publicly even when i'm
like ah candace went a little overboard
on that one i'm like i know that is you
that really is you and we we told the
story once but the day that lockdown
started you were on my show in l.a we
didn't know at the time we were taping
that lockdowns were about to happen
right um you were caught literally
coughing up blood you were coughing up
but your your friend or your assistant
at the time was there also she was sick
yeah david's looking at me like we're
going to be trapped in the house for
months with candice he's going to die
here like it's all over but you were
like you were just like no i don't have
covet i'm fine like it has something to
do with the pillows at the hotel yeah
and everyone's insane and i'm gonna get
the hell out of here yeah that was so
funny actually in retrospect like the
worst timing of me having an allergic
reaction to feathered pillows and like
your husband was not buying he's like no
no she's dying
but googling like to see like what was
happening but yeah you know and that was
that was actually the last of an idea
before they sort of locked down
everything and all my events you know
necessarily got cancelled but not
because of me i mean i attended
everything um you know i was pregnant
during covert i traveled the country i i
traveled the world i went to croatia um
i went to england i i just did not have
this fear i can't explain it it was just
it was too convenient um and it also
obviously didn't help their case that
they had predicted the coronavirus
pandemic the world economic forum a year
prior you know i think what we're
dealing with right now is a very
sinister evil globalist agenda um and
that is not a conspiracy i think that is
a fact and uh they want to exert control
over every single element of our lives
and unfortunately you have people that
are pliable to that control um because
they're fearful and also people that are
just lazy so one element is that people
are happy to be controlled because
they're fearful the other element is
because control is easy if you don't
have to think for yourself and somebody
just plugs you into a system and says do
this i mean
freedom is hard freedom is hard work
personal responsibility is hard growing
your own vegetables hey that's pretty
hard right it's kind of easy just go to
the grocery store and have it being
prepared people don't like to do things
that are difficult they want things to
be handed easily for them and that
that's why we have you know the
extraordinary welfare system that we
have why are you not afraid i know
you're not but everyone is basically
afraid seemingly but i i don't know is
it your wiring is it something you
learned very early on like why do you
always you see the thing in the distance
and you just go right to it for as many
times as twitter tried to take you out
or new york times or whoever it is you
just keep going and going and going yeah
you know i i get that question all the
time and and the truth is that like i'm
my granddaddy's granddaughter i mean he
just was a tough guy he just passed in
september i obviously dedicated my book
to him
my first book to him and you know i have
just always looked at my life in
comparison to his and it's the reason
why when people talk about their
oppression and i think of a man who grew
up in segregated south who never ever
ever spoke about being oppressed never
spoke about why people were racist never
spoke about how the white man was after
him he just got up every day and he
worked and he did that from a time he
was five years old on a sharecropping
farm i find this generation of
individuals to be a little bit pathetic
i think we're a little bit pathetic i
think you know the greatest generation
that ever lived uh you know yielded the
most pathetic generation that's ever
lived which is which is we're walking
among walking among us today we just
can't do anything for ourselves and i
don't want i don't want to be that and
the other thing is i was just i'm just
wired this way i was like this since i
was a little girl um my parents always
tell stories about me like i was just
one of those precocious kids that just
never allowed an adult to tell me what
to do without reason
i never responded to arbitrary authority
like i was one of those kids that if
your parents were like well you know
clean your bed or santa's not gonna come
i would say like you tell him not to
come right
um and so they were always laughing and
having to close the door to reprimand me
because i was kind of like this little
adult and i think in my character is
really just that i'm i i respect
authority um but the authority can't be
arbitrary it needs to make sense and if
it doesn't make sense you're just you're
and you're okay with it then you know
that sets up the grounds for slavery and
i'm not a slave
you are not a slave that is for sure uh
but will you be a politician will i be a
politician um i get this question all
the time and i used to say no and now i
i say never say never um you know i've
had those conversations with my husband
before about what it would actually
mean um
and i definitely would never be in
congress i can tell you absolutely not
i've done two of those hearings i would
rather honestly pull out all of my
fingernails that was one of your best
moments the one with you and ted lou was
like really incredible and then remember
we had that event i forget i don't even
remember where we were that night but
like you left that event you destroyed
everyone there yeah and then you just go
on with your life yeah i mean these
people are just are are real losers
setting up all these hearings but but
are you nervous in any of those things
like i do this for a living too and i
don't really get nervous but i haven't
sat in front of congress
and just destroyed them let me tell you
something congress works for you not the
other way around i actually think that
the way that that whole little
auditorium is set up is wrong why are
they above me yeah i should be literally
there yeah they're literally above you
and i believe that we should literally
be above them i don't even like the way
it's set up and this is the idea we've
gotten this idea that they're above us
they're not they literally work for us
and and and the majority of them on on
the democrat side are a bunch of
scumbags and they're working to destroy
this country they've sold us out um a
lot of them or have been in dc forever
and are just corrupt and trying to fill
their own pockets so i had no fear i was
angry
at the obvious setup and the attempt to
play me um and i was happy that i was
able to expose them for what they were
but i don't have fear you know of people
that are essentially my employees
do you
have anyone that you've been trying to
talk to to get into a debate with that
has refused them there's got to be some
but you've you've done you've done a
couple of these like with russell brand
who you had major differences with and a
couple other people i find it very hard
to get these people to talk at this
point because we have racist homophobic
tickets
is there anyone like that's like on your
list that you feel like if you could
just get them to break maybe it would it
would do something really big you know
not anymore because obviously there's
just been this long frustration with
realizing that they love to talk about
you to garner clicks but when you say
hey show up if you're about it show up
they always say no i mean i think even
last week we invited anna kasparian i
think she's dedicated hours and hours
hours of coverage of me and i have
dedicated literally zero seconds of
coverage to her and i said okay let's
hop on the show and have a civil
conversation and and she declined so
um i russell brand is an amazing human
being he really is and he's saying stuff
the reason why he was willing to host me
and he's willing to host others is
because he genuinely believed what he
was saying right if you genuinely
believe what you were saying even if
it's wrong but you believe it to be true
i can deal with that right and we can
talk we can have a conversation because
we both want to become better and we
both want to discover the truth if you
know what you are saying is a lie and
you tell about lie day in and day out
you have to hide right because you can't
face yourself and you can't face the
truth um so i always think that that
that kind of marks the difference in the
personalities that we see on the left
and there's not too many of them that
are willing to sit down with people on
the right so out of all the people that
i've interviewed and we've talked about
this many times privately but out of all
the people that i interviewed we
finished that first interview i turned
to david i was like that girl
is going to be a superstar it was just
so obvious but did you have this plan at
all like i know you were kind of curious
and you were figuring it out and there
were one or two things that i asked you
about politics that you were kind of
like i don't know yet i don't want to
comment on that yet which i thought was
pretty impressive actually
but you have just like marched forward
the machine has tried to destroy you how
many times now
you keep it keep a running count
definitely have lost count and
you know i think again kind of hinting
at the naivety of that first interview
which is really beautiful to watch is
that i just never could have imagined
that people would try to destroy me i
never would have imagined even that i
wasn't allowed to not have an opinion on
some things that i wasn't allowed to
grow as a person and say i'm still
learning because i was still learning i
didn't i had ideas and feelings about
things but i didn't really have the
facts on my side and i had no idea when
you're in politics it's just that
they're just looking to expose you and
she's a fake she's a fraud oh look she
doesn't know this she's stupid so i had
to grow up pretty quick you know and and
really kind of sharpen my figurative
sword and really get ready and do a lot
of studying um but yeah i i could have
never imagined i had no plan i was just
saying what i thought to be real and
what i thought to be true yeah and i
know that you're not just saying it
because every time i've been with you
when we've done road gigs together or
whatever like you've got 10 books with
you we had dinner at your house last
night you're you're working on farming
now like you're always just trying to
learn more and more and i will be
welcomed at your off location site right
when the group goes down and everything
yeah when the grid goes down yeah i i
actually as you just hinted on like i'm
kind of going through this thing now
where i realized that you know we are
all dependents and we are all on welfare
if we don't know how to grow our own
food and support ourselves and i think
that that really speaks to
the drama of this administration
of realizing that i know a lot of
americans empathize with the idea that
we feel like we're losing our country
and that we really have communists in
the white house um and you know we are
we are watching all of americans be
depressed and in that vein i said to
myself you know if this really does hit
right if we are suddenly living in a
communist country in three years four
years however you want to call it
can i can i fend for myself yeah two
months right uh can i fend for myself
can i grow my own food what do i know
about living off of the land um so that
is something yeah that i'm just now
learning now and what better place to do
it than in tennessee right i mean
everybody's you know farming hunting uh
so yeah that's kind of another thing
that i'm exploring now can you believe
that you live in tennessee i mean i said
to you guys last night like you so are
obviously in the right place so happy in
the house is great and little george is
great like you've just embraced it but
do you kind of sit back and go wow i
ended up in tennessee five years ago
little youtuber from philly like and
here i am now
and on your own set with your own crew
and the whole thing married to an
englishman in tennessee if you had said
to me that first day that we sat down
like here's here's what's going to
happen you're going to end up living in
nashville tennessee uh when you're
married to an englishman that you have
gotten to engage to after two weeks yeah
of knowing each other um i would have
thought you were nuts and my life has
been pretty nuts and pretty
unpredictable um you know tennessee in
my heart i think i maybe thought i would
end up in texas i love texas i love the
texans and obviously opportunity came
knocking in tennessee and now that i'm
here i could never imagine living
anywhere else like this is fully where
we want to raise our family we think it
is the greatest state we love the people
there really is something about the
tennesseans joining me today is a
youtuber who has done
pretty much the scariest thing that one
person can do she has come out as
conservative the scariest of all words
candace owens aka red pill black welcome
to the reuben report thank you i'm so
happy to be here right now i am very
happy excited to have you here
should i be calling you candace or red
pill black how are we going to do this i
guess people are calling me red pill
black so either or you can call me
candace yeah yeah you said you were just
walking down the streets i'm like yeah
there's red pill black and i'm like i'm
candice but i'm glad it's catching i
like redpo black so so before you were a
youtuber which you're actually pretty
new to you you went by candace i went by
candace yeah all right well i feel like
we're going to be on the level so i'm
going to go with candace
so you have a you have a crazy story an
interesting evolution you've suddenly
caught fire and you're doing pieces all
over the place you're on the daily wire
this morning i saw you on jesse waters
was it this past weekend right a couple
days ago saw a clip of that um you're
bouncing around you're making moves
who is this candace person all right
let's just do some history for the
people that don't know about you at all
um i am honestly i'm just a girl that
makes videos uh the history is i grew up
in stamford connecticut i went to school
at the university of rhode island um
pursued a degree in journalism which is
quite ironic whoa
someone that studied journalism that's
trying to tell the truth yeah
yeah absolutely um after college i was
in a lot of student loan debt you know i
came from a family doesn't have any
money whatsoever and i had to just pay
it back so the smartest move for me was
to go into finance i hit the ground
running in new york city worked a
private equity firm for four years
left that firm and wanted to do my own
anti-bullying startup thing that went
really sideways when the left tried to
do hit pieces on me during the election
and that was my red pill moment really
so wait how did doing an anti-bullying
thing get you caught up in the left so i
don't know if uh many people that watch
this show are familiar with the
gamergate scandal i certainly wasn't i
think most of my audience is
familiar-ish but like nobody fully gets
it yeah but feel free to take us down
that road for a little bit yeah so long
story short um that whole scandal is
built on a girl named zoby quinn who
says that she was attacked by anonymous
white men on the internet um and people
were saying that that wasn't true and
she said that it was
and they were anonymous how did she know
their skin care i don't know if you read
the pieces in the media it's fascinating
you know yeah uh so i was doing an
anti-bullying startup that i was really
passionate about and i got a phone call
from her and i put up a basically a
three-minute video on kickstarter
teasing what we were gonna do i said
this one sentence which was a figure of
speech that i think
set the alarms off i said what we're
doing is figuratively lifting the masks
up off of trolls at the time she was
working at twitter she was working for
twitter for something called crash
override network and i immediately
received an inbox from her on twitter
saying she'd like to talk to me about
and try to convince me that the project
that i'm doing is bad which is very
interesting so she calls me up and i
have no idea who she is i don't know
what gamergate is i don't know what
doxing means and she says you have to
pull your project because uh
people actually don't want to find out
who harassed them said i'm a victim but
i never want to know who harassed me on
internet like she was basically arguing
a point that didn't make sense if she
was actually harassed on the internet
then obviously my technology would be a
godsend because they never figured out
who harassed her and i said you know i
appreciate the phone call uh this isn't
really making sense to me yeah you know
it sounds literally the reverse of what
you'd think she would have called you to
say absolutely like she should have been
on board with what i was doing i totally
appreciate the phone call but i'm not
gonna pull my kickstarter and she
started crying
and
she said if you don't it's going to ruin
everything and she told me that she
spends time on 4chan because of what she
does and she saw that people were
already talking about my project and if
i didn't pull it they
these anonymous white men and trump
supporters you have to remember this was
during the election cycle yeah we're
going to come after me and dox my family
which essentially means put up their
personal information so people can try
to kill them that's what she says so she
said this is what they are going through
so she was oddly threatening you with
being doxxed but it wasn't she that was
gonna doxx you she thought i was a total
[ __ ] i think you know and i'm like okay
uh i'm not pulling my project she hangs
up the phone crying within two hours we
were absolutely inundated about 4 000
emails via kickstarter like you know
die die die you know pull your project
and they have these super obvious screen
names like you know trump or die you
know
trump 2020 white man behind computer
that's a good one
so
i'm like is she kidding all men by the
way everyone was like you know dave at
you know bob at no woman and magically
everything that she tried to warn me
about came true within a couple of hours
of me refusing to pull my project
so i tweet
very quickly again not really knowing
the bread and butter of the gamergate
scandal i said all i can say is that 100
after speaking with zoe quinn this girl
was never harassed she's doing the
harassing
and the next morning i woke up the
guardian the washington post and new
york magazine were all calling me
i was a nobody with a kickstarter that
was three minutes long kickstarter
pulled my project and the next day big
media and in my head i'm thinking you
know you know journalism major
washington post amazing like you know at
that point i consider myself a liberal
uh democrat if you will and um so i was
like great i'm gonna talk to them i'm
gonna tell them about this girl they're
gonna write the piece you know
bad feeling where this is about to go
this is about to go completely sideways
okay so i i speak to a person named
jesse single he works for new york
magazine and he's like yeah i saw your
tweet not a fan of mine no yeah well he
is a journalist uh
journalist hitman as i like to call them
and he speaks to me he's like yeah i saw
your tweets i just wanted to speak to
you about what happened you know super
nice
yeah and i i tell him everything i'm
like yeah you know zoe called me up open
and shut case obviously she told me to
pull my project i didn't and then i got
harassed he instead writes this article
the tone of it was essentially
essentially trying to gaslight me oh you
know she seemed like a nice girl but she
got dragged into this conspiracy theory
zoe actually is a girl that was harassed
you know and at that point i realized oh
my god like the media is going to try to
kill my project and these journalists
are absolutely lying so the washington
post called me and i had the good sense
to actually record it i just turned on
my camera and said something something
fishy is here and this girl was obvious
this girl caitlin dewey was asking me
questions and she was trying to figure
out who was funding us
and
her her job or her role was to cut off
the funding cut off the legs of social
autopsy so it could never see the light
of day
and
she started calling around so i actually
got a tip that she had already written
the article and she was going to try to
smear me and i essentially went back and
forth with the washington post i had
caught her in a live via email versus
what she said on the phone and they
pulled the article last second and told
me i wasn't important enough to run it
anyways when i threatened to sue them
wow yeah all right wait there's so much
here and it's so related to everything
and we haven't even fully got to your
political awakening yet yeah so first
off i love that you said they're they're
hitmen yes journalists
yeah because the phrase i mentioned to
you right before we started i've been
saying they're activists not journalists
but they're hitmen absolutely it's what
they really are so you wake up to all
this how did this then how quickly did
that jump to the way you thought about
politics instantly i mean i i was i
became a conservative overnight you know
i realized that liberals were actually
the racist the liberals were actually
the trolls and then at the very same
time you have to remember this is april
2016. trump is on the screen saying that
the media is lying that cnn is fake that
all of this you know it all began to
resonate with me because i realized that
everything he was saying was true so i
no longer bought into this idea when
they you know they were calling him a
racist a rapist a white nationalist
everything i bought none of it because i
knew that the media hired hitmen and
they were doing the most ridiculous hit
job on donald trump from start to finish
of his campaign yeah all right so i want
to put trump aside for a second but we
will get back to trump but i'm just
completely fascinated by your story so
okay so you get this now about the media
right right but did it so what changed
with you within you politically when you
say you went from being a liberal to a
conservative like did you change on
economics or on abortion or weed or gay
marriage or you know when i think back
on it i just i don't even know that i
ever really was a liberal i didn't care
about politics do you ever think about
this i'm just a girl i was trying to pay
back my student loans i wasn't involved
in politics i didn't really know what
being a liberal meant what being
conservative meant i think at the end of
the day i was always a conservative i'm
pretty rational i'm very fact-based um
uh in terms of i will always value like
you know economics above like social
issues and that sort of thing is i
understand that that should take a back
seat obviously i mean you don't want to
become a third world country you know
you know while screaming about yeah
exactly so um i think i was always
a conservative or more conservative in
that regard but i started really deeply
considering politics my positions on
everything because of that experience
yeah where are you on the social stuff
um
i think i'm
what specifically what well like gay
marriage or oh i support gay marriage
yeah i support gay marriage
i'm not really sure about abortion i
don't really have a position on that
just yet i think through that a lot i
just have i have so many people and
friends that have been through it
um wow look at you a conservative saying
i i don't have an answer on that yeah i
don't have i thought i thought you guys
are all supposed to be yeah
rush to judgment
yeah now i'm open and i make it very
clear to everyone that i'm still
learning i'm still developing i don't
want to be one of these people that sits
down and pretends i know every that i
know absolutely everything because i
think that that's the problem in the
world right now is that everyone is
pretending to know everything and people
aren't willing to learn and if i can go
from someone who thought that they were
on the left to someone who is i think
more centrist and more conservative in a
matter of 365 days
then it's
would do me a lot you know a lot of good
to continue to keep listening and to
continue to keep growing when you
started
coming out you you did that great video
when you were red pill black way back
when coming out as a conservative and
did you expect just to get love and then
next thing you know you get some love
but like the crazy hate
you know i would say the thing that
surprised me the most um and it's
something that i never forgot about
actually charlie kirk i guess sort of
had more of a vision that i was gonna be
uh very successful and gain a lot of
followers you kind of had that sort of
that same vision too i didn't see it in
the beginning i was just sort of doing
what felt right and he sat me down and
he made me uh read an article of things
that can change in your life when you
gain a little bit of fame and i i read
it sort of you know uh okay this is good
to plug into the back of your mind but i
don't know this is going to actually be
applied into my life and you know now my
husband actually says to me a quote he
doesn't know which beetle said it but
he's
apparently uh they said fame doesn't
change you it changes everybody around
you right and i think that's just such
an interesting quote so one thing that i
experienced jumping into this was i was
the same candice i've always been this
candice i've always been the outspoken
candice i've been a little different
i've always been convicted whether i was
convicted uh as a liberal and thinking
this is exactly who i want to be and
help my convictions um i i was always
the same person so to watch uh people
spin me into a caricature and then i
think the worst part was losing family
members that totally shocked me um so
when i was reading your chapter and
thinking about you know the shock and
you speak about someone who was
literally at your wedding or was invited
to your wedding invited didn't didn't
respond to the wedding invitation but
yeah i was invited to my wedding
went through the exact same thing i had
family members who didn't even respond
didn't even honor
my uh wedding with a response uh you
know because they i i was a conservative
so that was somebody that you just you
can't deal with anymore and i think that
is sort of
one of the biggest shocks i think of
knowing that you can be the exact same
person and rather than discuss an idea
with you um you're just considered
completely done you're just completely
barred um from your close families and
your friends and that's such a valid
point when you're giving your list of
things um for people just yeah i love
that the advice that you give in in each
chapter knowing that your friendships
are going to change your friendships
change a lot if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell